- Oh my gosh.
It's great to see both of you.
- Thank you.
- Oh, it's so great
to meet you.
- Oh, that's nice.
- Your music has always helped me so much,
through so many hard moments
in my life, you know?
"Since You've Been Gone," really helped me
when my dad left the house-
- Oh wow.
(Kelly laughing)
- But you know, now it's my-
- He's like, "Thank you."
- But now it's, "My Life
Would Suck Without You."
- Yeah. I like that.
Thank you, that was very nice.
- Thank you so much.
- I'm a big fan of what y'all are doing.
I think this is the coolest thing ever.
And I think a lot of families,
especially, I come from
a family where I actually
was estranged.
I had an estranged father and
it didn't end up working out.
And what I think is beautiful
is that it was hard for y'all,
but now you have this really amazing show
that's like, really cool
and it shows hope, I think,
for a lot of people.
'Cause some of us try.
- Yes, absolutely.
- Some of us try, you know,
and you try and you try,
and it just doesn't work.
And so it's a really beautiful thing.
So I'm excited to talk about it.
But before we do that,
I have to say it's the 20th
anniversary of your sitcom,
"George Lopez."
- Already!
- Yes!
- Oh my goodness!
(audience applauding)
- [Kelly] It's so funny.
So what's your favorite
memory from that time?
- Well, you know, it's very tough, Kelly,
to be 42 in the morning and 61 at night.
(Kelly laughing)
But my favorite memory,
I think, is, you know,
the odds of of having a television show,
and having it be successful,
are like a million to one.
But then to see your young
daughter be around the set,
five years old, seven years old.
Couple of times she was on the show.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then to go back,
and then see her now as
this incredibly intelligent
and forgiving young Gen Z-
- Yeah.
- Is therapy well spent, Kelly.
- Yeah. So wait, what was
that experience for you
at five and seven?
I'm curious 'cause my
kids have been around set
and they're six and eight right now.
- Yeah.
- Was that cool
to be on set?
- I mean it was amazing
'cause, you know, you always hear,
especially from school,
especially, like, you know,
"Oh. your dad's on TV. Your dad's on TV."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But, you know, going and being able
to see how people work together,
just seeing my dad being
able to do what he does
and me laughing along with him,
and you, know, I used to go
and actually make craft services around.
I used to actually make
little quesadillas.
- That's my kid's favorite.
- And I used to walk around
and give them to the whole stage-
- Oh, you're a polite.
My kids just take from
craft craft services.
- I know!
- You're like serving people.
My kids are like, "Where are the M&Ms?"
(George laughing)
- Yeah, that's amazing.
- You know, but it's like,
you know, formative of
being the backstage,
seeing how things work, you get to see,
and also how hard your parent works.
You kind of get to have that
work ethic instilled in you
when you kind of, at least it was for me.
- So nobody tells you in the moment,
they wait 14 years and they say,
"You worked so hard. Thank you so much".
- And look, I literally
was about to say that.
I'm like, that's literally why I do.
I bring my kids sometimes
to work because I'm like,
I don't want you to think
I'm just like, leaving.
I'm the breadwinner.
You know, I'm the one making money for us.
I'm the one like holding it down
and it's nice for them to get to see.
I think they appreciate it.
They're like, "Oh, we see what you do."
And I think that is actually
cool 'cause they don't get it.
They just think, "Why is
everybody else mom get to come
to science lab and you don't?"
And you're like, I try.
But do you remember the first time
that you made your dad laugh?
Did that feel like success?
- Yes. You know, I used to
love "Singing in the Rain."
It's still one of my favorite movies
and there's a song that
says "Make Him Laugh."
And there's a whole sequence
where there's a dummy,
and he's playing with the
dummy and throwing it around,
and I was like, oh my God.
That was one of the
first things I really saw
that I was like, you can
be crazy, and slap stick.
and funny.
And so I remember my, I
had my mom go to Universal
to like one of those little
shops and get me a little doll.
- Yeah.
- And I did it on the couch
in the middle of the living room.
- You reenacted it?
- Acted it from the beginning to end.
And, it was, you know,
being able to perform.
I think being in a house of performers
and people being in the industry.
You know, my parents
have always been like,
"Go for your dream."
Just try to be the best comedian
that you can be.
- Yeah.
Speaking of children, you
wrote a children's book, right?
- I did write a children's book, yes.
It's called "ChupaCarter"
- [Kelly] Chupacabra, like the, okay.
- And it's about a young boy
who befriends a chupacabra
and he grows up, his grandparents,
like myself, my grandparents raised me,
and I would always spend
a lot of time, Kelly,
looking at, at the moon at night,
and I would wonder, looking at the moon,
where all the people would be
that were gonna be in my life
when I was an adult.
So it's one of those kind of metaphysical,
but it's also very Latino.
You know, all of our stories
are, you know, horror in genre.
Even kids stories, you know, La Llorona.
- They are!
- La Llorona and her kids.
And then, I was telling this white woman
and she was listening to me going,
"Well I hope you called Child
Protective Services because
(Kelly laughing)
if you didn't, you're
as guilty as your aunt."
(Kelly laughing)
It was a story,
- No, it was fine.
- It was a story.
So wait, can you explain the chubacabra,
for those who don't know?
- A chubacabra is what would be,
it's a type of animal
that could be a human-
- It's like wolf hybrid.
- It's wolf hybrid of a goat.
Maybe it eats goats.
No one's ever really seen it.
It's in South America,
but then it's in Mexico,
and it's out here in Los Angeles.
- [Mayan] It's like a Big Foot figure.
- Like a Big Foot.
- Yes.
- I was gonna say, is this
like a Big Foot thing?
No one's seen it?
- Yeah.
- It's like a Big Foot in
a smaller, Latino shape.
(everyone laughing)
Or like a Big Foot in Halloween
candy, the little fun size.
You're not afraid, and then
all your bloods drain from you,
then you're afraid.
And so it's about befriending somebody-
- Evil.
- And, you know,
it's like E.T, you know,
I mean just not even
in these immigration,
everybody wants to go home at some point.
So it's a bit of that.
They take a journey and
they find each other.
And then from not having a family,
the ChupaCarter family help my little self
and put a family together.
- Oh, that's great.
- Yeah.
(audience applauding)
- So the news show, "Lopez Vs. Lopez"
is based on your lives, right?
- Yeah. It's loosely
based on our real life.
- [Kelly] Is that hard?
- You know what, I'm not
gonna say it's loosely.
I'm the one that did all that was wrong.
It's not a loosely based.
- It's like, I know, but I'm
just saying, is that hard?
I don't know. It's hard for me.
Sometimes I write a lot about
my real life in songs, right.
It's hard for me to like, rehash that.
- Yeah.
- Is that hard?
- I have to say there are
times where it is challenging,
but where I like to think is that,
this is such an opportunity to heal
and I always wanted my
pain to mean something and-
- Yeah.
- You know what,
as you have done, like to reach
out and carry much as people
and know that healing isn't linear
but you're not perfect and-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, just having empathy, you know,
as you get older you start
to see your parents as people
and-
- Yeah.
- You know, maybe you
understand some things.
You don't have to forgive
them, but you can understand,
and-
- Yeah.
- You know, going backwards and healing
but also rebuilding something
stronger for the future.
- [Kelly] You're very healthy.
- I'm very therapized.
- Wow.
I was like-
- Everyone's like,
"Where have you been?"
- That's amazing!
- I'm like, "Therapy."
- [Kelly] I was like, wow.
(audience applauding)
- I would say that that
message is probably conveyed
much better in song.
It sounds better somebody saying
♪ You were never there for me. ♪
As opposed to, "You were
never there for me!"
- Yeah, yeah.
If you lighten it with a
nice melancholy melody.
- Yes, yes. Exactly.
- But it's good though, that
y'all have that communicative,
I wish I would've had that.
Like, my father passed
away, so we never got that
and I tried so hard.
A lot of people really
want that, and desire that,
and don't get that.
- Right.
- So it's really remarkable and awesome.
- We believe, you know, the first show
had a different slant.
You know, this is fathers and daughters,
and that relationship is worth, you know,
preserving and trying to get back,
if there's fathers out there not speaking
to their daughters.
You know, when I was
growing up it was very tough
and people would just
disappear from your lives.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I finally realized that as an adult
that I couldn't, and didn't wanna do that,
or go down that road anymore
and that this person right here
was the one love of my life
and the one I would never
let go for anything.
So I would-
- Oh wow.
I love that.
So, it's based on your lives.
So do y'all also have a
lot of comedy with it?
You have a lot of humor?
- Oh yeah, no. I have to
explain that to people.
- Yeah. I love that though.
- Not but it comes
from a real place, and the
comedy is, you know, release.
I feel like laughter is such
a release and so, you know,
there are sometimes where, the only time
that we could communicate was
having jokes at each other.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
Welcome to all my friendships.
- Yeah, exactly!
- I was like, wait, what?
- You know, you give
your friends a hard time,
you give your family a hard time.
- That's love. That's a love language.
- Yes, absolutely.
- For some of us.
So why or how long did you
two go without totally?
How long was it, that y'all didn't talk?
- Sometimes it was on and off,
but I think the longest
was almost three years
that we didn't speak?
- It was three years.
- Yeah.
- It's a little fuzzy for me
because it's the same three years
that those drinks, Four Loko, came out.
(audience laughing)
So...
- So it could've been three years,
it could've been been three minutes.
- Could have been four,
could have been...
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(Kelly laughing)
- Night time, daytime. Come on.
It's the same really
attitude you wanna have.
And I think sometimes the
further you get away from it,
the more pride, or the more
that someone is stubborn,
the more time that goes away from it,
and you know that it's
probably right to make amends.
But it becomes so difficult
to take that very first step.
- But it takes two people to do that.
- That's exactly, that's right.
- Yeah. That's the catch.
So how did you mend fences
enough to make the show?
I guess my question is how
did you go from not talking
to all of a sudden like,
"Let's do a show together?"
- Really the pandemic.
You know my dad is immunocompromised.
My mom donated a kidney
to my dad 17 years ago
and so, you know, he had underlying,
I was like, what is it, underlying?
- Yeah, like a situation
to where he shouldn't have
been around people with, yeah.
- Exactly. So you know, we
kind of really came together
as a unit, my mom, my dad and I.
And you know, I started sharing that,
it was even interesting,
my family really hasn't
been together in 10 years
and so I was just kind of watching.
And they made one TikTok,
I was just filming them 'cause
I thought it was hilarious.
'Cause, you know, even though
my parents were divorced,
they had so much history together.
- Yeah.
- You know,
my mom was still trying to fix his hair,
or pop his zits on his nose and, you know?
So I just thought it was hilarious
and so I just thought, you
know, we're all inside.
Someone might laugh and find this
and then I get it and it
has like 15 million views
in like, a day.
- I just love that y'all
came together in Covid
and like a lot of us didn't make it.
- Yeah.
- In Covid.
- No.
- Yeah.
Like a lot of us didn't.
- It provided opportunity
and I think, how we took it was, you know,
we can come together and
family was really important,
you know, taking inventory
of the people around you
and perspective.
- Fresh perspectives.
- They came over my house for my birthday
when we had one of
those pandemic birthdays
where people just wave
as they go by your house.
And-
- He actually had a mariachi band outside.
- Oh I love a mariachi band.
- It was great.
- They were just the
guys around the house,
(Kelly laughing)
And, you know, immediately, you know,
they come into my house
and just started to throw things away
that they felt didn't belong in the house,
although it's my house.
- Okay, you had like,
eight birthday cakes.
He had sent, like,
- You don't eat them all.
Yeah.
- But one was made by a woman
and the other seven were made in a store.
So the one with the woman
had to go in the trash.
- And then my mom threw it in the trash,
and then my mom brought
it out of the trash
and my dad's like, "Take it out."
And my mom's like, "Okay."
And she put it back, and he's like, "No!"
(Kelly laughing)
- And then I took it out of the trash,
cut a slice and ate it
because no one's gonna
throw a cake in the trash
at my house!
- Yeah. You've at least got to try it.
- It was tough to wash it
down with the milk I found
at the bottom of the cake,
but they were like...
- Dad!
(Kelly laughing)
- Oh my God, that's gross.
So wait, your dad famously plays golf?
- Yes.
- Are you into golf at all?
- I played in golf just
to spend time with him.
I actually retired at a very early age
because there was one
time that he took me out,
we were up in Pebble Beach,
and you know, I had my own
little set of clubs and-
- Your first time to
golf was Pebble Beach?
- I know.
- Congratulations.
- Well, thank you.
- I'm like, wow.
- I know. And so there
was a little course there
and, you know,
sometimes it's always
been Lopez versus Lopez.
We kind of sometimes
butt heads and, you know,
I was getting annoyed.
He was just trying to
teach me how to swing
and I was like, "Oh all right!
You wanna teach me how to swing?
I'll show you how I swing."
And I just put all my might
in it and I got a hole in one.
- What?
- I got a hole in one.
- You Happy Gilmored the situation?
- At 11 years old.
And I just turned around like,
"You know I can't see the ball."
And my dad's, all the blood
just came out of his face.
He just was white.
And then people back there were like,
"Did you just shoot a hole in one?"
My dad,
like, "Yeah."
- Cause you're-
- You know?
- Are you both emotions?
You're like angry and proud?
(Kelly laughing)
- Well no, I mean there's
a second half to the story
where the ball went in the hole,
and then Mayan somehow got the
golf cart stuck on the rail.
So two wheels were moving,
but none of them touched the ground.
So, it took a little bit
longer to get back to celebrate
than we would've liked.
(Kelly laughing)
- Because the golf cart got stuck
on the track.
- She was done.
She Happy Gilmored it.
- Yeah.
- I did! I did.
- And she was just missing it
by that much.
- It's all in the hips.
You know?
(Kelly laughing)